c'est sous la forme d'une lettre qui
n'annonce sa candidature ce soir aux
français voulaient bien sain derrière
parler vraiment de la crise en ukraine
et là il a fait il a fait une lettre
leur jeu vous et synthétiser la lettre
un d'emmanuel macron il dit depuis cinq
ans nous avons traversé en son nombre
d'épreuves terrorisme pandémie retour de
la violence guerre en europe rarement la
france avait été confrontée à une telle
accumulation de crise nous avons fait
face avec dignité fraternité il parle
aussi de son bilan et souligner un point
il ne referait peut-être pas tous de la
même manière nous n'avons pas tout
réussi dit le chef de l'état il est des
choix qu'avec l'expérience acquise
auprès de vous je ferai sans doute
différemment mais les transformations
engagées durant ce mandat ont permis à
nombre de nos compatriotes de vivre
mieux à la france de gagner en
indépendance au passage il lance un
petit accroc nostalgie qui ont sans
doute au candidat de droite c'est en
regardant avec humilité lucidité le
présente en hausse en denrées en hausse
et ne rien de l'audace de la volonté et
de notre goût de l'avenir que nous
réussirons l'enjeu est de bâtir la
france de nos enfants pas de ressasser
la france de notre enfance enrico macias
président est donc candidat à sa
réélection voilà pourquoi je sollicite
votre confiance pour un nouveau mandat
de président de la république je suis
candidat pour inventer avec vous face
aux défis du siècle une réponse
française et européenne singulière je
suis candidat pour défendre nos valeurs
que les dérèglements du monde menace je
suis candidat pour continuer de préparer
l'avenir de nos enfants et de nos
petits-enfants voilà c'était donc la
lettre du chef de l'état il a fait ça
sous forme de lettre c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment voilà c'était compliqué aussi de
parler d'autre chose que la crise rend
du cred